I talked about my father's day how was  your father's day and I was it was  really great we just kind of hung out  and yeah my kids made breakfast and then  I got this it's I mean it's just great  they double yeah world's greatest dad  mug  I was really happy to get that kind of  strange because yesterday I got a  World's Greatest Dad  [Applause]  I mean it's kind of impossible I mean  there can't be two worlds greatest ads  well there are ESPYs yes there are Zoo  yours is a fake now no mine's the real  world's greatest - no yours is the fake  this is an authentic world's greatest  dad mom because I am the world's  greatest dad that's not true I'm the  world's greatest dad no I am it's time  for a world's greatest  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Applause]  [Applause]  wasn't that a great clip subscribe to my  youtube channel for an endless supply of  me  [Laughter]